Générique
...
-Dormir le jour pour travailler
la nuit, c'est le quotidien
d'1 salarié sur 10 en France.
Les horaires atypiques
le sont de moins en moins.
Pourtant, notre organisme
n'est pas adapté
à un tel rythme.
-J'ai compris que...
Il y avait une réelle pénibilité,
un réel impact sur le corps
et qu'il fallait que je trouve
des petites astuces
pour que mon corps comprenne
ce rythme
et qu'il soit
le moins perturbé possible.
-Lorsque l'horloge interne
se dérègle,
les conséquences
peuvent être graves.
-C'est un médecin
qui m'a dit :
"Eh bien...
"Cancer du sein et travail de nuit,
ça va ensemble."
-Pourquoi notre rythme
veille-sommeil
est-il aussi important ?
Comment mieux prendre en compte
notre horloge biologique ?
C'est le thème de ce nouveau numéro
d'"Etat de santé".
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans "Etat de santé".
Avec la rentrée de septembre,
fini les grasses mat',
les repas tardifs :
on change de rythme.
On entre dans des rythmes
journaliers plus réguliers.
Est-ce mieux
ou moins bien ?
C'est une problématique
passionnante.
Comment joue le rythme des journées
sur notre santé ?
On va explorer ça
avec Hélène Duez.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes chronobiologiste,
chercheuse en rythme.
Evidemment, quand on naît,
quand on respire la première fois,
on va dormir beaucoup,
et puis au fil de la vie,
ce rythme-là, interne,
il va évoluer.
Donc, l'horloge interne évolue
tout au long de la vie ?
-On a une horloge interne,
un petit mécanisme qui existe
dans nos cellules
et qui nous permet
de mesurer le temps qui passe.
Ca nous permet de nous adapter
à cette alternance jour-nuit
qui est engendrée
par la rotation de la Terre.
-Qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un rythme circadien ?
C'est quoi ?
-Circadien, ça veut dire
"environ une journée".
Ca vient du latin.
"Circa diem", "environ une journée".
Ca veut dire que c'est
un rythme d'environ 24 heures,
pas exactement 24 heures.
Notre horloge interne,
en tout cas chez l'homme,
ne génère pas
un rythme de 24 heures pile.
Donc, on a besoin
d'une resynchronisation chaque jour
pour remettre en phase
l'horloge.
-Vous êtes chronobiologiste.
On regarde votre parcours.
-Hélène Duez
est directrice de recherche
en chronobiologie à l'Inserm
et à l'Institut Pasteur
de Lille.
Depuis 20 ans, elle tente
de comprendre comment et pourquoi
notre métabolisme est contrôlé
par notre horloge biologique.
Son objectif à terme
est de s'appuyer sur ses découvertes
pour mieux prendre en charge
des pathologies comme le diabète,
les maladies cardiovasculaires
ou inflammatoires.
-Vous disiez
qu'on a une horloge interne
qui évolue tout au long de la vie,
mais il y a
ce soleil qui se lève
à une certaine heure
le matin l'hiver,
à une autre l'été.
En quoi ça interagit
avec notre horloge interne ?
-C'est ce signal de lumière bleue
qu'on a le matin,
qui est émis par le soleil,
qui va venir remettre notre horloge
à l'heure tous les jours.
-C'est comme si on remontait
notre montre ?
-Ca nous permet de redémarrer,
car la lumière,
grâce à l'horloge biologique
qui sert de relais,
va engendrer plein de changements,
et notamment un pic de cortisols...
-Ah oui ?
-...qu'on a le matin
et qui permet de mettre en phase
nos organes et cellules.
-Il faudrait,
dès qu'on se lève,
sortir dehors
et être exposé au jour ?
Ce serait bon pour nous ?
-Ce serait bon pour nous,
parce que ça permettrait
de renforcer ce rythme-là.
On ne perd pas son rythme
en ne s'exposant pas,
mais ça nous renforce.
-Il y a des choses passionnantes
avec cette horloge interne,
parce qu'il y a eu
des expériences qui ont montré
que quand on a ni le jour,
ni la nuit,
ce rythme de 24 heures,
il survit
à l'absence de lumière.
Infographie.
-En 1962,
un spéléologue français
a eu une drôle d'idée.
Michel Siffre a passé deux mois
à 130 mètres de profondeur
dans un gouffre
en Italie.
Son objectif : voir comment
son rythme veille-sommeil
allait évoluer
sans repère temporel.
Il est en effet descendu
sans montre, ni agenda,
et avec une petite lampe électrique
pour seule lumière.
Coupé de l'extérieur,
il disposait tout de même
d'une ligne téléphonique
pour appeler
une équipe de veille en surface
à chaque réveil,
chaque coucher
et chaque repas.
Ces horaires
étaient ainsi consignés.
Michel Siffre se levait,
se couchait et mangeait
quand il le voulait.
Il a peu à peu perdu
la notion du temps,
pensant que ses journées
ne duraient pas plus de 5 heures.
Mais en remontant
à la surface,
après deux mois,
il a fait une découverte historique.
Son cycle veille-sommeil
n'avait subi aucun changement.
Ronflement
Chaque jour, il avait dormi
environ 8 heures 30
et veillé 16 heures,
en tout : 24h30.
L'humain a donc bien
une horloge interne
qui règle l'organisme,
même en dehors de toute contrainte.
En revanche, ce rythme était
un peu plus long
que celui de la rotation
de la Terre.
Chaque jour, dans sa grotte,
Michel Siffre se couchait
et se réveillait
une demi-heure plus tard,
se décalant progressivement.
C'est pourquoi la lumière du jour
est si importante.
Elle nous sert de signal
et nous permet
d'être tous synchronisés
sur un même rythme
de 24 heures.
-Hélène Duez,
en quoi cette expérience,
quand même extraordinaire,
est intéressante ?
-C'est intéressant, car ça montre
la nature endogène de notre horloge,
qu'en l'absence
de tout signal,
notre horloge biologique
continue de générer un rythme.
-Donc, notre horloge interne
est plus puissante
que le jour et la nuit
que nous impose la nature.
-Oui.
-C'est extraordinaire.
-Elle est puissante,
car c'est un ensemble de protéines
qui modifie l'expression
de nos gènes,
de notre patrimoine génétique
dans chacune de nos cellules.
Ca a un rôle crucial.
-Il y a en revanche
quelque chose de pénalisant.
On va le voir
dans le reportage,
c'est quand on est
vie à l'envers,
c'est-à-dire quand on vit à rebours
du jour et de la nuit.
Là, on la secoue,
notre horloge interne.
-On la secoue énormément.
-On la secoue par manque de sommeil
ou par décalage ?
-Les deux. Les deux.
-Les deux, mon capitaine.
-Les deux sont vraiment
très importantes.
On la secoue
par un troisième facteur.
L'heure à laquelle on mange
est aussi un signal très fort
pour nos horloges,
et en mangeant à une heure
qui n'est pas propice,
on dérègle aussi nos horloges.
Ce sont les facteurs
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui.
Le travail de nuit
ou en horaires décalés n'est pas bon
pour notre horloge biologique.
-Pour "Etat de santé",
Marianne Cazaux a rencontré
ces travailleurs qui sont exposés
à ces rythmes plus ou moins décalés,
parfois totalement.
Quelles en sont
les conséquences ?
On regarde ce reportage
et on se retrouve après.
-Les humains ne sont pas
des animaux nocturnes.
Alice le sait bien.
Pourtant, cela fait huit ans
qu'elle travaille la nuit
et dort le jour.
C'est le lot
de nombreuses infirmières,
comme elle.
-Ce rythme, je ne le connaissais pas
quand je me suis lancée.
Je me suis rendu compte
du temps libre que ça dégageait.
-Comment s'adapte-t-elle
à un tel mode de vie ?
Tous les matins,
elle s'endort vers 8h30.
En ce mois d'août,
il fait déjà bien jour
dehors.
Et si Alice
a du temps libre,
c'est au prix
de son sommeil.
Elle ne dort que 4 à 5 heures
par jour.
-Je vois quand même une différence
avec le début.
Déjà, le vieillissement
de la peau,
les rides prématurées
qui sont apparues assez vite,
les cernes
qui sont plus marquées
qu'au tout début
de ma carrière.
Je me demande
si c'est quelque chose
que j'arriverai à tenir
sur la durée.
Je pense déjà à des reconversions
professionnelles.
Si je devais arrêter,
qu'est-ce que serait ma vie ?
-En attendant,
pour limiter les risques
sur sa santé,
Alice s'impose une routine stricte
pendant la journée.
Elle se lève et prend ses repas
à heures fixes,
mais elle manque souvent
d'énergie
pour sortir s'exposer
à la lumière du jour
ou faire du sport,
ce dont elle aurait
bien besoin.
-J'ai compris qu'en fait,
il y avait une réelle pénibilité,
un réel impact sur le corps...
et que très vite, il fallait
que je trouve des astuces
pour que mon corps
comprenne très vite le rythme
et qu'il soit
le moins perturbé possible.
Je pense qu'il y a
des petites carences qui se font,
même si on essaie de compenser
avec de la nourriture.
Il y a quand même des choses
qui ne se font plus
ou que je ne dois plus avoir
de la même façon qu'avant.
-L'organisme subit les assauts
d'une vie décalée
et les conséquences
peuvent être graves.
A Saint-Mitre-les-Remparts,
près de Marseille,
Sylvie est retraitée,
après avoir exercé
en tant qu'infirmière de nuit
pendant 30 ans.
En 2015,
elle a appris qu'elle souffrait
d'un cancer du sein.
A l'époque,
elle est tombée des nues.
-Je n'ai aucun antécédent
de cancer du sein dans ma famille.
J'ai une vie saine,
je fais du sport,
je bois pas
et je fume pas...
J'avais une ligne
assez parfaite.
En fait,
c'est un médecin
qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille
et qui m'a dit :
"Eh bien... Cancer du sein
et travail de nuit, ça va ensemble."
De là,
j'ai effectué des recherches.
-Elle découvre alors
cette étude
de l'Inserm qui montre
qu'il existe bel et bien
un lien entre les deux.
Le risque de cancer du sein
est augmenté d'environ 30 %
chez les femmes
ayant travaillé de nuit,
par rapport
aux autres femmes.
-J'ai l'impression
d'avoir été trahie,
parce que personne
ne nous l'avait dit.
Si j'avais été prévenue,
j'aurais pu faire plus attention
à mon hygiène de vie.
J'aurais un peu plus dormi,
parce que je dormais très peu,
surtout en dernier.
J'aurais peut-être aussi arrêté
de grignoter la nuit,
ce qu'on fait à peu près tous,
alors qu'on sait que l'alimentation
est très importante.
Ca me motive
pour que de plus en plus de gens
soient au courant de ce facteur
de risque très méconnu.
-Aujourd'hui en rémission,
elle se bat pour faire reconnaître
son cancer du sein
en maladie professionnelle,
une reconnaissance accordée
pour la première fois
en mars 2023
à une infirmière mosellane.
Sylvie a bon espoir
que les choses changent,
et elle fait tout
pour se faire entendre
des décideurs.
Elle a créé
l'association Cyclosein,
pour sensibiliser à cette cause
de manière originale.
-Là, c'est qu'on était à Bruxelles,
à la Commission européenne.
"Le grand départ
de Saint-Mitre-les-Remparts
"pour Paris :
1104 kilomètres."
Notre arrivée à Paris
devant le ministère de la Santé...
-Elle a même pédalé
jusqu'à l'Organisation
internationale du travail à Genève.
En attendant un meilleur suivi
du personnel de nuit,
Sylvie part sensibiliser
les lycées
et les écoles d'infirmières
sur les routes de France.
-Impressionnant, ce reportage.
On précise que 10 % des salariés
sont exposés
à des horaires
complètement décalés, à l'envers.
En tout, 20 % vivent à des horaires
plus ou moins décalés.
Est-ce que vous diriez
que quand on travaille
de cette façon, de nuit,
sur évidemment un temps long,
il faut aller voir
un spécialiste du sommeil ?
-Oui, il faudrait être accompagné
par un spécialiste,
mais pas que, car en fait,
des choses
peuvent être mises en place.
Une exposition à la lumière
au bon moment
peut aider
à recaler notre horloge
ou éviter la lumière,
par exemple,
quand on sort du travail
en portant des lunettes de soleil
avant d'aller dormir.
Il y a beaucoup d'éléments
qui sont pas toujours connus
des travailleurs
en horaires décalés
et qui pourraient améliorer,
ou en tout cas
permettre de lisser
un petit peu les conséquences
de ce travail posté,
à condition qu'il ne dure pas
toute une vie.
-Essayer d'avoir
une forme de régularité
dans la prise de nourriture,
c'est important ?
-C'est important.
-Comme éviter de grignoter.
Ca a l'air dérisoire,
mais pas pour vous.
-En fait,
ce n'est pas dérisoire
et ça l'est d'autant moins
que chez les travailleurs postés,
il y a une envie plus forte
d'éléments riches en calories,
riches en sucre,
type barres de céréales.
Evidemment, quand c'est
sur deux ou trois jours,
c'est pas très grave.
Quand c'est sur toute une vie,
ça participe
aux conséquences néfastes
de ce travail posté
en augmentant, finalement,
le risque de maladies métaboliques,
d'obésité.
-On peut agir
sur ces choses-là.
Quand on voit qu'il y a
une relation de causalité
entre un rythme de nuit
et l'apparition
d'un cancer du sein...
C'est surtout des cancers,
dont on est sûrs qu'il y a
un lien de cause à effet ?
-Oui.
-Pas d'autres pathologies ?
-Le risque est avéré aussi
pour le développement
de maladies métaboliques,
mais c'est moins clair
pour les maladies cardiovasculaires.
Néanmoins, tous les éléments
scientifiques que l'on a,
que ce soit
de recherche fondamentale,
chez l'animal,
dans les cellules
ou les études épidémiologiques
chez l'homme,
tendent vers une augmentation
du risque cardiovasculaire.
-On a besoin de personnes
qui travaillent la nuit.
On en a besoin,
mais on s'interroge.
Est-ce qu'on est
suffisamment informés du risque,
en termes de santé publique ?
Quand on nous fait signer
un accord
ou un contrat de travail de nuit,
il n'y a pas marqué
en tête :
"Si, dans votre famille,
il y a un risque
"de cancer du sein,
vous êtes plus exposé."
-C'est vrai.
Je pense qu'il y a
un manque d'information,
de transmission
par la médecine du travail,
par les employeurs, et aussi
une méconnaissance de ces données
par nous tous,
par le grand public.
-On a commencé l'émission
en disant
que l'on ne dorme pas
de la même façon
selon que l'on est bébé,
ado et personne âgée.
Les ados,
on parle beaucoup du fait
qu'ils sont décalés,
ils se couchent à 4h et se lèvent
à midi. C'est grave ?
-C'est naturel.
-Pour la santé ?
-En fait, non.
C'est une évolution
tout à fait normale.
Les jeunes enfants se lèvent
très tôt et se couchent très tôt.
L'adolescent se décale complètement
vers la fin d'après-midi
et la soirée.
Quand on est à l'âge adulte,
de facto, parce qu'on a
une activité sociale,
on revient
à un horaire plus précoce.
Chez le sujet âgé,
on voit des personnes âgées
qui sont plus précoces,
qui se lèvent plus tôt.
Elles ont un sommeil plus léger,
plus fragmenté.
C'est une évolution
tout à fait normale.
Ce n'est pas néfaste pour la santé.
Le problème,
c'est que l'on s'oblige, adolescent,
personne adulte, etc.,
à tous vivre au même rythme.
Néanmoins,
certaines expériences pilotes
ont été réalisées
au Canada et aux Etats-Unis.
Certaines écoles démarrent
à 10h ou 11h, le matin.
-Le rêve !
-Le rêve pour les étudiants.
-Mais c'est une expérience,
pas des généralisations.
-Il y a pas de généralisation,
mais dans ces expériences,
très souvent,
les adolescents
ont vraiment bénéficié.
Les performances scolaires
ont été largement augmentées,
je dirais,
parce que l'on respecte
leur rythme
et on les fait étudier
au moment
où ils sont réceptifs
à ce qu'on leur apprend.
-C'est une meilleure prise
en compte de ces rythmes naturels.
Est-ce que vous diriez...
Il ne s'agit pas de se mettre
des cendres sur la tête,
mais plus on va,
moins on respecte les rythmes.
Les temps modernes
sont plus... pénalisants
pour notre horloge interne.
-Ils sont plus pénalisants
tout simplement
parce qu'on a aujourd'hui
un éclairage qui nous permet
de rester actifs toute la soirée,
une partie de la nuit.
On s'expose, par exemple,
à des téléphones portables
qui ont une lumière LED bleue
comme celle qui resynchronise
notre horloge le matin.
-Les médecins cherchent
de plus en plus
à prendre en compte
ces rythmes circadiens
dans les conseils de soins.
Reportage : Marianne Cazaux.
-Pour traiter
un cancer du pancréas,
cela passe souvent
par une chimiothérapie.
Mais dans ce service
d'oncologie digestive
et médicale
de l'AP-HP...
-Bonjour, monsieur.
-Bonjour, docteur.
-...les médecins comptent aussi
sur un outil plus inhabituel :
un capteur
qui enregistre les rythmes
circadiens du patient,
chaque minute, à distance.
-Ca, c'est votre rythme
de températures.
On voit qu'il est vraiment
très régulier,
après une phase initiale
où il était plus perturbé.
C'était il y a cinq ou six jours,
à peu près.
-Le moment où j'étais le plus mal
après la chimio.
-Votre rythme d'activité-repos.
Il est vraiment parfait.
-Pour Francis Lévy,
c'est loin d'être anecdotique.
-Avant que les symptômes
ne se manifestent,
on va voir se dégrader
les paramètres du rythme.
Ce sont des signaux précoces
d'altérations
de l'état de santé
de la personne.
-Au revoir.
-Au revoir, monsieur.
-Ce télémonitoring
est aujourd'hui à l'étude,
mais Francis Lévy a bon espoir
qu'il prévienne à l'avenir
les hospitalisations d'urgence
des patients.
Ce chronobiologiste
n'en est pas à sa première
recherche sur les rythmes.
Cela fait 50 ans
qu'il est persuadé
que la médecine
doit mieux
les prendre en compte.
En 2000, il a montré
que face au cancer du côlon,
les patients qui avaient
un bon rythme biologique
avaient une meilleure
espérance de vie.
En 2002,
pour la première fois,
il met en évidence qu'en détruisant
l'horloge circadienne
de souris
et en leur inoculant
une tumeur,
celle-ci poussait
2 à 3 fois plus vite.
-On a découvert
que ces horloges n'étaient pas
seulement dans le cerveau,
mais aussi dans toutes les cellules
de tous nos organes.
S'il y a des maladies,
ces rythmes peuvent
être perturbés.
Les horloges sont
mal synchronisées.
Elles donnent des heures différentes
selon les cellules ou les organes.
Un risque de développement
de pathologies survient.
-Les cellules tumorales aussi
peuvent avoir un rythme.
Alors, Francis Lévy
a décidé d'utiliser
ces horloges
dans le traitement des cancers.
-On avait conscience
que l'administration du traitement,
selon le rythme circadien,
ou que la détection de perturbation
du rythme circadien,
ouvrait un nouveau pan de progrès
pour la médecine,
mais on était assez peu
à le penser.
On m'a demandé
si j'étais devenu astrologue.
J'ai rien contre eux
mais c'est pas mon métier.
-Mais Francis Lévy
a fini par convaincre
d'autres médecins,
comme Sylvie Giacchetti,
qui a travaillé à ses côtés
il y a 30 ans. Aujourd'hui,
elle publie des résultats
enthousiasmants
sur le traitement
du cancer du sein.
-On a montré
que chez les femmes plus jeunes,
non ménopausées,
donc celles qui prennent
l'hormonothérapie
qui s'appelle le tamoxifène,
l'horaire de prise
est fondamental,
puisque les patientes
qui prennent le tamoxifène le soir,
la courbe verte,
ont un risque de rechute
qui est moindre que les patientes
qui prennent le tamoxifène
le matin.
-Lorsqu'elle prescrit
ce médicament,
elle ne manque donc pas d'indiquer
le meilleur moment
pour le prendre.
-Bonjour, madame.
-Bonjour.
-Je suis Emilie, l'infirmière.
Je viens vous poser
le traitement.
-Dans son service,
Sylvie a également demandé
aux infirmières
de bien noter
l'heure d'administration
des autres traitements.
-Après, je le renote
sur le logiciel.
-Et le bon horaire,
qu'on puisse n'utiliser
que les données informatiques.
Super.
C'est peut-être un petit effort,
mais finalement,
on ne peut pas faire
que ça ne se fasse pas,
pour la qualité des soins.
La structure circadienne
doit entrer en compte
parce qu'elle fait partie
de la façon
dont les êtres humains
sont structurés.
-Mais ailleurs en France,
les rythmes biologiques sont
rarement utilisés dans les soins.
D'autant plus que les spécialistes
doivent encore relever
un défi important :
celui de la personnalisation,
car ces cycles dépendent
de nombreux facteurs,
comme l'état général du patient,
l'âge ou le sexe.
-Sur ce graphique,
nous voyons les heures optimales
d'administration
en fonction
des différentes toxicités.
Il faut lire ce graphique
comme une horloge.
Les flèches pointent
vers les horaires optimaux
d'administration.
Donc pour les hommes,
on est plutôt
autour du matin,
vers 9h du matin,
et pour les femmes,
on est sur des horaires
d'administration optimaux
plutôt vers 15h.
On a donc une différence de 5 heures
entre les hommes et les femmes.
-Annabelle Ballesta doit prendre
en compte ces différences.
Le chemin vers la médecine
circadienne est encore long,
mais mathématiciens et médecins,
tous en sont persuadés :
il est grand temps
de l'emprunter.
-Hélène Duez,
c'est assez impressionnant,
l'impact que peut avoir
sur l'organisme malade
l'horaire auquel
on s'administre les médicaments.
-Oui, c'est spectaculaire,
mais en fait,
c'était presque attendu,
même si on l'a découvert
que très tard,
simplement parce que les médicaments
vont cibler
des processus ou des protéines
qui sont eux-mêmes
très souvent circadiens.
-Une question
très grand public :
l'horaire d'été,
l'horaire d'hiver.
On change toujours d'horaire.
C'est une décision européenne.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Il faut arrêter avec ça ?
-L'idéal, ce serait d'arrêter
le changement d'heure, évidemment,
d'avoir l'heure d'hiver
qui nous permettrait
de nous décaler moins
par rapport à l'heure solaire.
-Vous dites qu'à chaque fois,
ça dérègle un peu nos organismes.
-Je pense, en effet,
chez un sujet sain,
ce décalage d'une heure,
on s'y fait rapidement.
C'est pas dramatique.
Par contre, on voit,
par exemple, une recrudescence
des infarctus du myocarde
juste après le changement d'heure.
L'infarctus du myocarde,
on le sait,
il est beaucoup plus fréquent
le matin,
parce que notre organisme
est circadien,
et quand on décale
notre horaire d'une heure,
eh bien, d'un seul coup,
on augmente encore
un petit peu plus
l'environnement néfaste
pour notre coeur et nos artères.
Il y a des catégories
de la population
chez lesquelles ce changement
d'heure a vraiment un impact.
-On va revenir
au travail de nuit,
parce que dans cette émission,
la tradition,
c'est de poser une question
à un député,
un élu de l'Assemblée nationale.
Hadrien Clouet est député
de La France Insoumise NUPES
de Haute-Garonne,
et vous avez voulu l'interroger
sur des méthodes,
des mesures de prévention
pour la santé,
pour les personnes qui travaillent
en horaires décalés.
On écoute sa réponse.
-On a une progression
du travail de nuit.
Depuis des années,
il y a de plus en plus
de travailleurs de nuit.
Les examens médicaux
dans le monde du travail
ont reculé ces dernières années.
On défend le rétablissement
d'un examen médical
avant l'embauche
et périodique durant la carrière :
il faut surveiller aléatoirement,
faire des examens régulièrement
pour être sûr
qu'il n'y ait pas de pépin.
Il faut indemniser
le travail de nuit
et le payer d'avantage.
Le préjudice doit être reconnu.
Il faut aussi le limiter.
Il faudrait qu'on ait
un nombre d'années maximum
de travail de nuit,
que cela donne lieu
à des bonifications
pour les semestres,
pour partir plus tôt à la retraite.
Bref, il faut réorganiser
la vie des salariés
qui exercent de nuit,
parce qu'il y a des activités
- police, pompier, hospitalier -
où on a besoin de travail de nuit,
mais il faut une compensation forte
sur la santé :
des jours de repos accrus, un départ
plus tôt en fin de carrière,
une limitation du travail de nuit,
et une rémunération digne.
-On parle de plus en plus
du sommeil.
Ca aussi,
j'imagine que pour vous,
c'est un progrès ?
On a observé,
pour conclure,
une perte générale moyenne
de 1h30 de sommeil de l'individu.
C'est beaucoup ?
-Oui, les conséquences
sont similaires
à celles du travail posté.
Il y a vraiment là
quelque chose à faire.
Après, le sommeil, il faut essayer
de le préserver le plus possible.
Ca veut dire un horaire régulier,
ça veut dire éviter les écrans
1h, 1h30
avant d'aller se coucher.
-1h30 avant le coucher,
alors qu'en général,
on se couche devant son écran.
-Il faudrait reprendre
un bon vieux livre.
-Dieu vous entende,
si je puis dire.
C'est très compliqué,
parce qu'en effet,
c'est plutôt le contraire,
mais vous devez avoir à coeur
de faire passer
ces messages qui sont
de moins en moins respectés,
mais peut-être demain,
on éteindra les téléphones
1h30 avant le coucher.
Merci d'avoir été avec nous...
-Merci à vous.
-...dans "Etat de santé".
A très vite.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA